LEGISLATURE PASSED A BILL A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO TO. ALLOW
VETERANS WHO.
HOLD ON IT INJURIES
TWO HOW THAT HE CONSIDERED FOR
SENTENCING THIS BILL DOES THAT
WORK FOR TWENTY FIFTEEN RATHER
THAN JUST COURSE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR. PARTICIPATION
THANK YOU VERY IN WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THE SORT TO SPEAK TO
THE COMMITTEE I WILL BE.
VERY BRIEF PLEASE DON'T TALK
PASSED YES BUT A TRANSCRIPT.
WITH CITATIONS TO THE DATA A
SIGN. A BILL.
BUT IT WASN'T. MY NAME IS JOHN
COACHING I'M RETIRED SILICON
VALLEY CORPORATE LAWYER.
OCCASIONAL LOW LECTURE NO
BRIEFLY OFFERED THREE
RESPONSE
WELL THE SOCIAL REFORM.
FIRST AND FOREMOST SOUP WHICH
YOU AFFAIRS.
JUSTICES SERVE.
BY ALLOWING RECENTLY
SAID IT'S BETTER INSTEAD SERVICE
RELATED MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
STANDARD IN MITIGATION.
SAYING
SHOULD NOT THE SAME OPPORTUNITY
BE OFFERED NEWSLETTER AND SEND.
IN EARLIER YEARS.
THE SECOND TWO MILLION OF
INCREMENTAL COST
COSTSAVINGS CONSERVATIVELY
ESTIMATED IN THE RANGE OF FOUR
TO TEN MILLION.
.
SENATE PERSONAL DELIVERY OF
VETERANS PERSPECTIVE DO THESE
REMARKS.
BEFORE ATTENDING LAW SCHOOL A
CERTAIN VIETNAM'S OF YOUNG
RANGER LIEUTENANT LEADING HIM.
TO.
BUT I SPENT EIGHT MONTHS IN ARMY
HOSPITALS RECUPERATING.
CURRENTLY VOLUNTEER AT SAN
QUENTIN ON A WEEKLY BASIS.
WITH THE VETERANS HEALING
VETERANS AND I'VE COME TO KNOW
INMATES WHO SERVED. IN
AFGHANISTAN ETHIOPIA IRAQ.
AND VIETNAM.
FROM MY PERSONALEXPERIENCE I
HAVE NO DOUBT THAT MANY OF THESE
MEN SUFFERED FROM UNTREATED POST
TRAUMATIC STRESS.
TODAY WE KNOW PTSD IS A MAJOR
CONTRIBUTOR.
DESTRUCTIVE BEHAVIOR PATTERNS.
THEY WERE SENTENCED COURT WAS
UNDER NO OBLIGATION
SOONER THAT FROM WE SHOULD WORK
TO PUT IT RIGHT.
WHICH BRINGS US TO THE THIRD
COMPELLING REASON THIS
LEGISLATION SHOULD PASS AB EIGHT
SIX AND FIVE.
IT IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION THANK YOU OR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AND SHARE RAINY ON BEHALF OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL WE DON'T HAVE A
CRYSTAL.
AT THIS TIME BECAUSE THE BILL
WAS AMENDED INTO FILM BILL BILL
NUMBER FIVE WE WERE STRONGLY
SUPPORTED.
EIGHTY SIX
FIVE MINUTES ANTICIPATE THAT WE
WILL PROBABLY WON'T LIKE THIS
BUT
THAT MAYBE YOU'D LOOK AT.
EXTENDING IT INTO SOME SORT OF
POST CONVICTION RELIEF I'M.
THERE MAY BE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SERVED THEIR THEIR FELONY
SENTENCE BUT HAS BEEN AVAILABLE
TO THEM.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN REDUCED TO
A MISDEMEANOR I'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH ESPECIALLY THE COURT
ADVANCE TO ARE DEPORTED BECAUSE
OF A FELONY.
IT MIGHT BE ANOTHER TOOL THAT
WE COULD USE POST CONVICTION
POSTS.
SENTENCING POST SERVING.
TO HELP MITIGATE THAT TWO
FACTORS OF WHY SOMEBODY BENEFIT.
IS.
HELP PEOPLE GET THE TREATMENT
THAT THEY NEED RATHER THAN BEING
LOCKED OUT ON.
BUT SEE EYES AT THE POINT THAT
YOU'RE MAKING IS ALSO.
THANK YOU VERY NEW QUESTIONS
COMMITMENT VERSION.
YOU MICHAEL ISLANDS FOR POLICE
PASSION SERVICE.
THANK YOU AND I KNOW YOU WORK.
FUNDED ON THE MATTER QUESTIONS
ARE. ASKED SO CHAIRED RECOMMEND
AYE VOTE. MEANT SECRETARY CALLED
WORLD EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
EMOTIONS YOU HAVE TO
APPROPRIATIONS JONES SAWYER BY.
I LACKEY A LACKEY I. GARCIA AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE